- It feels incredible to
be a part of the list.
If you had told me a couple
of years ago that this was
gonna happen, I would've told
you that you have to be lying.
It's totally unbelievable.
(dramatic music)
I'm Arantxa Unda, and
I'm the CEO of Sigesa.
It's the company that we do
coding and analytics tools
for management decision
support in health care.
I have a bit of a different story
to some other entrepreneurs.
I actually started my
career working in finance.
I was not very convinced by that.
And my father, together
with some other partners,
he upstarted a company
that did health care IT.
And I decided to give it a
try, and work for the company,
and became really passionate
about health care,
and a firm believer of the
value of universal care
and public health care systems.
So I decided to go to the
US, pursue an MBA in Harvard
to get more managerial skills.
And on my way back to Spain
I raised some financing,
bought out the company, and
I've transformed the company
and I'm looking to expand it.
It's very different to just
like work at the company
to just actually own the
company and have the challenge
to transform a company looking
to, trying to transform
an industry as a whole.
So I think it's knowing
that what you're doing is,
actually has an impact,
that you're working
to transform an industry.
And it's something that you
firmly believe in, like I do.
For me, it's public health care systems.
And I think that some days
when you have a hard day
and you have to wake
up and just go to work,
you're realizing you're
doing something that really
adds value, and that keeps you going.
So I think it's find something
that you're passionate about.
Also be very persistent in your work.
And also for someone
like me, if you've worked
in something like finance
or consulting before,
to understand that working in a startup or
at a small company that's
growing, it's very different.
That you have to make sometimes
decisions pretty fast,
and you can't have all the
analysis you want with you,
'cause otherwise you'll get
stuck in paralysis by analysis.
You need to trust yourself,
and you also need to be,
just trust your gut.
So for us the next step is scaling.
We're building new
products for our portfolio,
and we're looking to scale
in different countries, too.
(dramatic music)